this is one of those stories that if
Hollywood wrote it like a screenwriter
pitches it every person in the room
would say get the F out of the room this
is beyond unreal like this is not could
never happen the I mean I I don't mean
to get into the a little bit but like
the story is insane it it doesn't you
know what I mean yeah it would be if it
wasn't a true story it would be the
dumbest movie of the year people would
be like this is a stupid wish
fulfillment story that Sony cooked up to
like entice all you Gamers but like but
yeah the fact that it really happened
grounds it in this true wish fulfillment
story of like it's an incredible true
story yeah yeah uh one of the things
though that is cool is that Neil used
that new Sony Venice 2 camera and he got
to like create really cool angles and
really put you there what was your
reaction when you saw the camera work
and what he was going for uh I mean he's
really a mass like he was doing stuff
early on I realized what a genius simp
he was by simply this one thing like he
was using lenses I kept saying to him
when are you coming in for the closeup
cuz he would have cameras that were like
a football field away and I was like
when when are you coming he was like I'm
in for the closeup right now I was like
what he said he's shooting on really
long lenses uh from really far away so
he could get in real close but have the
camera be really far away cuz he wanted
to feel both close and far away like
you're observing but you're also up
close and there was just a an aesthetic
to that that was quite genius I was like
oh you're working on a level that is
very subtle uh and then he he also was
doing this crazy stuff with drone
cameras where they had all these guys
with FPS drones going 160 mph weaving in
and out of these cars that were and they
were just crashing them all over the
tracks I mean it was nuts what they were
doing and I was like like this film is
uh you know he's taking risks he was
doing his work he's an artist and I knew
he would fight the right battles and I
knew he would make a movie that we could
be proud of well one of the things is
and I I don't know how it is for you but
when you find out that the cameras are
all the way away but he's going in for a
closeup does that change all of a sudden
your performance when because I would
imagine if you know the camera's right
here and you know that it's the closeup
maybe that changes what you're doing a
little bit I mean you think that you're
going to get better better if you know
that and actually you generally get
worse because you're more self-conscious
so the fact that he was just you didn't
even know the cameras were there you
kind of thought you were doing a wide
shot and he's in tight was liberating
because you never really knew what he
was shooting he'd also set up like 10 or
12 cameras and we would just do stuff in
real time like cars would pull into the
pit Lane we would do a full change I
would talk to a Stunt Driver who was
meant to be Yan outside blah blah blah
and they just the car would just take
off and he would have like 10 cameras
and some of the close-ups that were in
there that I didn't even know just stuff
I would improv would be pivotal in the
movie and he was just capturing stuff
and he watches all of it really closely
and puts together cobbles together this
great film so in that way when I think
that I can control things I'm usually
worse and when I just let him do his
thing if I'm in the hands of a good
director and I'm just sort of in it
living you know he he showed me that
it's better that he controls that yeah
one of the things that's cool uh is that
sometimes you know the way it is uh you
might be on a green screen you don't
know how you're going to actually make a
movie but so what was your reaction and
what was it like when it's actual cars
actual racetracks everything being
practical it's great I mean it's just
really liberating sometimes it's a
nightmare for sound because you you're
trying to do a scene and those cars are
so loud you can't even believe it but it
feels like you know it feels like you're
Galvan izing a team of people it it has
even ramifications that aren't just the
specifics of the car like it feels like
there's a group of people that know how
to do actual things in the actual world
and ads are getting people together
drivers and so it it has this um it
feels like an event and it feels on set
like you're making something as opposed
to just like yeah we can do it again cuz
it's green it's like we got to get this
because we only have a certain amount of
time with these drivers and these cars
and the and the way they're moving so we
got to get it and there's something
about that event nature to it that that
makes us all sort of stand taller and
you know do better you also know you're
going to be doing a lot of ADR down the
road but anyway uh so I only have a
little bit of time left with you uh so
uh you know um violent night did very
well uh when do you think you're playing
Santa
again I mean before the writer strike
There Was You you know maybe something
that came in we'll have to see where it
fits if they can resolve all these labor
issues if the studios would please go to
the table and end these labor issues we
could shoot all kinds of things I'd love
to give to the people but yes we are
we're in process good I would like to
see you play that role again um you're
also going to be one of the few people
that gets to play in both the DC and
Marvel sandbox which is amazing
um have you started recording for
Creature Commandos where are you in that
process yeah we record a bunch of stuff
and I mean not only do I get to play in
the DC Universe I get to play in like
the James gun DC Universe which is a
whole new exciting thing um I I didn't
know what it was when it was sent to me
I met with James and he sort of laid out
a lot of stuff it's it's really exciting
he considers it some of the best stuff
he's ever written it's
hilarious uh and the character is great
I think you know I think it's been
announced that it's Franken Frankenstein
and uh you know uh it's a very colorful
terrific character so yeah we've started
to shoot stuff it's uh I'm not one to
really break but during this it is
wildly funny stuff so yeah we we're
shooting it's hilarious I can't wait for
people to see it the thing about signing
on for this project is that James has
said you're going to be the people that
sign on are going to be doing the
animation the video games the live
action it's everything so what was it
like to sign on to something that you
might be doing this for the next 8 to 10
years well I talked to him about that
you know and there also is this feeling
of you're like well is this the right
one or what are you getting yourself
into blah blah blah and this character's
so
good uh I I wasn't really aware of this
character in the creature Commandos
thing I wasn't even really aware of the
Creature Commandos and then I started
reading up on it and this character is
so rich and hilarious and like layered
that uh it was exciting it again it
feels like it's this new world where
they don't lock you in anymore like I
feel like Marvel learned that lesson as
well it's not like you know if you don't
want to do it I don't think they're
going to make you do 20 movies but I
think it's something where I just love
these worlds so much that it's a joy to
do and a joy to work with someone so
creative so if they want me to do 8 to
10 years of this I feel like I I'll
check my schedule but I'll try to free
up some
time on that note sir thank you for
answering that I wish you nothing but
the best have a fantastic you too have
fun in
Malta